the corona virus has mutated some
strains are far more infectious it
doesn't prove that this new strain is in
fact more infectious hello fellow
skeptics it's me Abbi there is a lot of
information flying in to our eyes and
ears at any given moment and it could be
hard to tell sometimes what's true
what's not so I grabbed three of the
most common talking points that you're
probably seeing on your feet two truths
1 lie and I did a little digging truth
number one it's okay to go outside it's
really nice out here but social
distancing is still the best way to
control the spread both things can be
true I'm a big fan of this viral blog
post by an immunologist who delightfully
puts all of his credentials on the front
page of his blog but he's very upfront
about not claiming to be an expert and
some of the work he cites hasn't been
peer-reviewed yet so I ran it by our
senior health reporter Anna she said
looks good the whole post is a solid
read but the main takeaway is this
successful infection equals exposure to
the virus multiplied by time
basically the more viral particles
you're exposed to and the longer you're
exposed to them the more likely you'll
be infected sorry about this gross
picture but this cough can apparently
contain up to 200 million virus
particles a number that I could not find
an original source for but shows up
everywhere so let's take it with a grain
of salt point is if a sick person coughs
right into your face breathes - but to a
lesser degree your chances of getting
infected are gonna be high which is why
going over to a friend's house not ideal
but if you just walk by someone on the
sidewalk
chances are you're gonna be fine because
you're limiting the amount of time
you're being exposed and the number of
particles you're being exposed to by not
locking yourself in a room full of them
so going outside is super low risk as
long as you're staying physically
distant I think this quote from a
previous Insider article sums it up
perfectly outside a bit of an inside
open space is better to closed fewer
people is better than more people and
stay away from sick people or better yet
stay home if you're not feeling well
yourself thanks Eric truth number two
the virus that causes kovat 19 is
mutating all the time it's true that
viruses mutate viruses mutate more often
than practically any other organism but
we shouldn't be treating it as a big
scary thing which a lot of places have
which is exactly how this study turned
into this then had to be corrected into
this first it's worth noting that this
paper has not been peer reviewed which
it does say in the study at the top in
bright yellow right before saying it
should not be reported in news media as
established information but peers have
been informally reviewing it on Twitter
and at least one epidemiologist bill
thanks the paper itself is fine so based
on that the problem is in interpreting
the data the first headline says that
the mutant corona virus is more
contagious than the original but while
the mutated strain of the virus is more
prevalent we don't know if it was the
mutation that gave it a leg up there are
other factors like the fact that this
particular strain happened to show up on
the East Coast which responded to the
outbreak more slowly than the West and
this is something that happens all the
time but mutation is not a dirty word
they'll put it fast in his tweet
mutations are what happens when genomes
replicate comes with the territory like
showers in the springtime poetry and if
you want to know what a mutation
actually is I made a whole entire video
about it that you can see here and now
the lie kovat 19 only kills older people
and those with pre-existing conditions
here's why this meme really gets my goat
the goal seems to be to quell some panic
but what it really does is spread
misinformation as far as we know at this
point anyone can die from this disease
old people healthy people children yeah
unfortunately there have been a couple
documented cases this study is a little
on the older side but it's still the
biggest one we have the death rate is
absolutely lower the younger and
healthier you are but do you want to be
one of the few and that point 2% guy
from my Facebook feed I'm gonna say no
as new information comes out about who
this virus is most dangerous for and why
the risk by population adjusts which is
a really complicated topic so if you
want to learn more about it I probably
did a video here but new information
only
is what we know about risk it doesn't
eliminate it and yeah I don't want to
die from this but I don't want to be
sick either this CDC data suggests that
30% of cases and 20% of hospitalizations
in the u.s. are people between the ages
of 20 and 44 and recovery can be a slow
and painful process that can take months
bottom line low risk doesn't mean no
risk so protect yourself and the people
around you by being cautious not panicky
but cautious so there you go two truths
and a lie
Adam to your hinge profile and if any of
this sets off your this is complete crap
ometer great stay skeptical back check
me my sources are in the credits